foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone
my name is parashar I'm the product
manager for Kodi and we have Mike from
gitlab with me as well today we will be
talking about vertex ai's Kodi apis we
have a full pack agenda today so hoping
to also interact with you at the end of
the session
I'll be covering these topics and the
most important one with the demo
hopefully it excites you and encourages
you to try the apis immediately
so what are Kodi apis the Kodi apis are
essentially apis which we launched in
April in experimental and now they are
in GA and we also did a ga refresh two
days ago these apis are designed to help
developers
and also analysts who work like
developers in many cases writing some
code
with their day-to-day tasks so it could
be creation of website it could be
writing some SQL queries it could be
data science it could be python C plus
plus you name it and we have it there
are three apis one is code completion
which is low latency and designed to
help with the IDE code assistance so
when you're writing code in an IDE you
you can use that the second one is code
generation which is used for generating
full block of code based on your
comments or natural language prompts and
the third is code chat API which is a
multi-turn version of the code
generation API so it's essentially
helpful in creating a bot and retains
the context now we also support many
programming languages python Java
JavaScript and in fact I'm excited to
say that we have more than 30 plus
languages which are supported now and
and then all these apis essentially are
integrating uh into ID of your choice so
beat your own IDE or it could be an ID
like gitlab as well so uh we'll talk
about that during the session and we
allow even customization so you can
actually tune the model with your own
data so very excited to share more as we
go through the next so let me yeah this
is the first API which is like I said
code completion API so you can see here
in the slide that the API is actually
running in in a collab notebook it can
be in any other ID and it retains the
context so basically whatever code is
before and after it looks at that and
then helps with same line and next line
code completion we have refresh the
model as well so now the new model is uh
able to even do more uh do better code
prediction so all the supported
languages work even better
the second API is code generation API
and here uh the idea is like you can
give a code prompt like help me write a
python code to do function X and then
you'll get an entire block of code so
the difference between code completion
and generation is essentially completion
is same line and next line low latency
whereas generation is normally three to
four seconds when it's in non-streaming
mode and in streaming mode it's very
instant but the idea is to generate full
block of code and and not just the same
line and next line so so that's the
difference between the two and we have
refreshed the models so now they support
streaming model tuning many more
languages more use cases and these
models are now available to you we
launched it two days ago you might have
seen even in the keynote so and they are
in GA so please write out and and the
third API is code chat API which is like
I said a superset of the code generation
API and the idea here is to help you
create Bots and and when I say Bots is
essentially it's not only just helping
write code but also other things which
are associated with code so like
documentation generation unit test case
generation and even helping you fix code
or translate code so all these use cases
are supported by this so when you
integrate it into a chat bot of your
liking then you can actually send
context and and get responses which are
relevant to the conversation
uh all these apis also have source
citation right uh the data sets that we
use are permissive data sets so whenever
there are public references uh to this
then we actually cite uh this so we
don't block generation of code the code
is still generated but we cite the
source and the license associated with
it so you can actually uh depending on
your Enterprise's policy you can do post
processing and figure out if this
license is permitted to use or not and
then then either block the code or show
the code but but that's the citation
part and the next responsible AI feature
that we have is what we call as toxicity
Checker in this case we actually block
the generation of code so unlike source
citation where we generate the code and
cite the references when when it comes
to toxicity Checker we actually block
the code so in in this example I'm not
sure if the folks at the back can see
but I'm trying to generate code to
generate curse words and and the
response is like no I'm I'm not allowed
to do that so these are models which are
running in parallel so there is
essentially the model which is doing
code completion generation code chat and
then there is a source citation model
and then there is also the toxicity
Checker okay uh and then all these
models are accessible from model Garden
as well so just uh search for Kodi and
you will see all three models with all
the details on how to use it including
all the documentation links and
everything so it's it's there as part of
our foundation models in in model guide
now what about use cases right so you
might ask like which API is useful for a
particular use case so we expanded the
number of use cases that we support with
our model refresh so depending on the
use case you you have to pick and choose
the end point so code completion like I
said is code Gecko and essentially it's
low latency same line next line code
completion but we have the Bison family
of models which are larger models and
then it's basically for code generation
you would use code bison and then for uh
code chat where it's multi-turn you
would use code chat bison and uh both
these apis are capable of not only
handling code generation but also other
cases which are part of the software
development life cycle right so you can
do the documentation you can also
generate unit test cases you can
translate code have
have the API even explain the code to
you right and you'll see some of these
things in the demo as well
uh the languages like I said we expanded
the number of languages that we support
with our latest model refresh uh if you
had asked me this question like last
week I would let's say we support around
14 to 15 languages but not anymore we
support more than 30 languages now and
many of these languages are very new in
fact I I can't understand many of these
languages but yeah the model can so feel
free to try it out and in in some cases
you can actually even do translation so
you can translate from one language to
another as well okay
and are all when I say the improvements
uh we we see 10 to 25 percent
improvements across these languages and
will continue to so that's as compared
to the V1 so V1 which was there until
last week as compared to V1 the latest
models so the the way you would access
it is code bison at latest or just write
code bison to call the API uh and and
that's how it's you would access the
model and the improvements versus our
previous generation model is anywhere
from 10 to 25 percent
uh I'm also excited to launch adapter
tuning support for code models and I
assume you would have seen some of the
sessions talk about adapted tuning the
idea here is to allow you to customize
the model with your own code base right
so uh you can start with as little as
100 label documents this is supervised
fine tuning so you do have to provide
label documents and it's in the form of
input output pairs right so essentially
The Prompt is help me write a python
function to do X and then the response
also is your providing your training
data set but you can get started with as
little as 100 and the training time is
normally at least the ones which I tried
it's it's anywhere from three to four
hours but it depends on how big the data
set is so it's very fast as compared to
weeks which which you would take if you
were to do full fine tuning right so not
only is it faster it's quicker to get
started but it's all also cheaper to
host so when you use adapter tuning you
are just paying for the training you
don't have to pay anything additional
for the inference the inference
inference price is the same as you would
pay if you were to do prediction on the
base API we don't charge extra if you
use a custom endpoint for for by using
adapter tuning okay uh and and then the
most important thing which resonates
with a lot of customers I talk to is the
ability to own your own data so whatever
data set is used to customize the model
it doesn't come to Google like we do not
use it to improve our base model it
stays in your gcp project so you have
control over it and whenever you are
calling the endpoint which is customized
again it's used only during that request
response so otherwise like we at Google
don't see what data set you have used
for training and things like that so it
resonates a lot with Enterprises who
actually cannot share that data for
improving the basements on the other
side if you have data sets which you
want to contribute to us then we work
directly with the customers there are
agreements in place and then it goes
into the base model but not if you use
adapter tuning okay uh and and then like
I said there are many use cases which
are possible so some of the customers I
work with are using adapter tuning to
use their own libraries and in some
cases they are also using it to improve
uh the the performance of the base model
right because I'm seeing anywhere from
an optic an uptick from five to ten
percent when you just provide 100
samples uh with adaptive tuning and this
is all in the UI so you don't have to go
to a python notebook to actually train
the model but you can use the UI upload
your data set just do the clicks like
what I'm saying and then you will see
the entire vertex AI pipeline which is
uh which is actually doing the model and
and then from there the test is
available
I have to use the mouse at the stage
yeah and and then the final but last but
not the least the most exciting feature
that we also launched is a text to SQL
uh now this is this is a capability on
top of our code generation or code bison
endpoint and here this this feature
enables you to actually generate SQL
from natural language prompts so if you
are if you the way it works is you
provide the data set and the service
account ID so we query the schema and
then we execute the generated prompt
against that data set and and and then
give you a response so you might have
heard that large language models can
generate code but sometimes the code
might create something which is actually
not in the data set so we are trying to
solve that problem here with text to SQL
so so it leverages the existing code
generation code bison endpoint and then
on top of it like when you put a query
that helped me find out all the
customers which have made more than 100
000 requests in last one week so then
that's the natural language prompt you
would provide alongside that you will
provide all your tables as part of the
data set and the service service account
number then we will take that natural
language prompt generate SQL multiple
sqls actually so there is a configurable
parameter also available to you in terms
of how many samples that you want us to
try so it could be three or five and
once we generate it before even showing
it to you we actually execute it against
the database and and then based on the
confidence score of the execution we
give the SQL back to you right now we
support bigquery and more databases are
coming in the future
with that let me switch to the demo
okay so
um I'm going to show you two two demos
which are kind of real life stories for
me so my wife is a doctor and she she's
not good with coding uh so every evening
there is this conversation at our home
like what to cook for dinner so I was
like why don't you try Kodi apis so what
she did is basically created a piece of
paper just drew like a website with some
form and some radio buttons and things
like that and then we just converted it
to like a prompt which is there so
that's what I'm going to show you today
and uh The Prompt is essentially uh let
me just copy a second
okay the The Prompt is basically to
create a website which uh based on the
ingredients which I provide and and the
time of the day then it then it it
suggests what recipes to cook right so
so that's the idea behind it so I'm just
going to give this prompt and pink is
our favorite color so we also have a
pink background hopefully it all goes
through
so uh that that's the that's the
exciting and the nervous part when you
use large language models because
sometimes it cannot be deterministic and
we are trying uh many new techniques
like grounding as well to make it more
deterministic so this is with a single
prompt now we generated the entire
website code including the CSS and HTML
not only that it also cited the sources
so now you can see when you're using
this code you have Clarity in terms of
what are the references for this code
right so I'm going to copy paste and it
does even have functions for PHP and
things like that so it it assumes that
those things are there in the back end
but in uh if it's not then you can
actually plug it in but it gives you a
skeleton of how to get started so I do
have
uh the code so I'm going to just copy it
and there is a PHP and everything in
there
so I'm just going to use the HTML piece
of it
and it's not going to work because of
the PHP part so I know that so I'm going
to remove the PHP portion because that's
not plugged in
and yeah here is the website right so
you can see I did a live demo a wristlet
as always but the model didn't fail me
and that's what I love about the models
that it works so it's the background and
everything and not only that like I
didn't specify that I wanted breakfast
dinner so it did pick up that there is
lunch breakfast so now you just work on
it further and now you use the code chat
API essentially to interact further that
okay make the buttons rounded or help me
write the code to connect to a database
and it will do all that right so so
that's the first one now the second one
which I wanted to show is
um like I used to be a data scientist
earlier and uh I'm pretty sure that this
would resonate with many of you that you
join a team and then there's some code
base which is there which probably
doesn't have explanation or comments and
then you are asked to work on that code
not only that you're asked to optimize
it right so in in the second demo we are
going to run through that software
development life cycle essentially so
there is a piece of code I don't know
much about it so I'm going to ask the
Kodi apis to help me understand that
code so my prompt is the code and then I
prefix it like I'm new to this code so
help me understand what it does right so
I'm going to send it to the API
and while it does that anyone wants to
guess what this code is doing
it's it's sorting basically so the API
figured out okay there was nothing in
the code which says it's sorting in
terms of like insertion sort or
something like that but it figured out
that okay this is insertion sort not
only that if you see here that uh it it
actually explains uh everything that it
does now how about we actually even
optimize it so let me actually Zoom it
in case you can't see it at the back so
I did that and and so my next question
is basically how to make it faster right
because for people who have used
insertion sort you would know that
probably this code is not very optimal
so now I use the word it but it knows
that okay it's in the context of the
code I provided previously so let's see
what it comes back with
yeah so now you can see that it came
back with suggestions so things like
using uh let me let me just quickly uh
help you this so there is binary search
part which is there and then it also
suggests multi-threaded implementation
so not only is it optimizing the code
but it's also suggesting like in terms
of the execution pipeline when you do
that what else could be done right so so
I showed you code explanation of a code
which didn't have comments and then I
showed you how to optimize that code and
and even uh probably so you can keep
going like you can actually ask this to
not only add unit test cases add more
comments even change variable names so
when you plug it into your CI CD
workflows or things like that then
essentially whenever a developer submits
some code you can call the API to add
comments unit test cases documentation
to it and and uh have a prop workflow
where where you know that whatever code
is being submitted is going to execute
and it's it's ready for your staging
right now let's run this code so I have
already copied it here so the the first
part of the code is basically what what
I provided right without the comments so
I'm going to run it
uh and then the time it took is uh
0.008 so uh seconds and then I'm going
to run the second code where it is where
it has optimized it by adding binary
search to it uh and then
let's see how much it takes
so it's
0.0001 so it's eight times faster in my
own test I have actually seen that it
can be even 15 times faster but this is
just one example that we like I'm not an
expert with insertion sorting but just
by using the apis I'm able to not only
understand the code what it is doing but
also optimize it and and I have tried
even uh conversations like where it can
simulate two developers discussing
design so you can say okay what are the
pros and cons of each and then it will
actually do some kind of a role play as
well so so you can do a lot of stuff
with the apis by using the right prompts
okay and then there is also
vulnerability scanning which can be used
uh so the apis are very powerful and the
underlying models with the new refresh
now I'm very confident that it's it's
able it's it's like in the world class
category now with this can we go back to
the slides please
okay where is the clicker
now let me introduce Mike and this is
one of the most exciting part of the
session so we are going to have a q a on
the query apis the state of the world
and especially with this in the software
development life cycle and also how
gitlab use it you want to introduce
yourself and get started absolutely hi
everybody I'm Mike floating I'm VP of
products at gitlab uh super excited to
be here today to talk about what we're
doing
cool thank you uh so my first question
is uh what is the biggest opportunity uh
for generative AI uh in terms of the
impact it can have on gitlab's customers
yeah so maybe a little background on
gitlab to set some context uh so we are
our vision is to be an all ops platform
so where everybody can contribute and so
kind of our current stage of evolution
is we're a devsecops platform uh so a
single kind of application for all those
constituents to collaborate share
information and ultimately build
software and deliver experiences so you
kind of think about what that means you
have a lot of different constituencies
on the same platform so you have product
managers you have Engineers obviously
you have sres you have platform
Engineers you have security folks
compliance folks legal folks all
collaborating and communicating together
so kind of having a single data model
having a single workflow engine access
permissions it's a big win in and of
itself but we think there's a much
bigger opportunity there to facilitate
better communication because if you
think about those constituencies they're
all coming from different backgrounds so
everybody kind of has their own
strengths their own way of viewing the
world their own way of communicating and
so sometimes it takes some some work to
kind of frame things in terms that
somebody else can understand so as
product managers like my team loves us
every day we kind of talk with Engineers
we'll never be as deep technically as
our best Engineers but we need to be
able to get deep enough into the weeds
to have an intelligent conversation
about trade-offs of implementation
decision for example
so we see uh AI as transformative and
that pun is intended thank you Google
for inventing Transformers but we really
see it as transformative and
facilitating a lot of that communication
because it can reframe things in terms
that somebody can understand so I can't
even tell you how many times I'm asked
to weigh in on an issue and I open it up
in gitlab it's three years old there's a
hundred comments on it and I say you
know what I really need to clear my
calendar today in order to get up to
speed on this particular issue so
imagine a world where I can just click a
button say summarize this issue explain
it to me in context that I can
understand and that's a huge
productivity when and it gets me to that
conversation with the engineering
manager much faster and you kind of you
know all those constituents I enumerated
if you do the math on how many different
pairings and kind of translation
Communications it's just a huge win for
productivity
and so I think when we look at AI uh we
really kind of have three guiding
principles number one it needs to
facilitate and enhance every step of the
sdlc so it can't just be about
generating more code because if you
generate 10 times more code but you
don't introduce efficiencies later
Downstream you're going to break your
CID CD you're going to have you know too
many Mrs to review and it's just really
not going to be overall net productivity
benefits so AI throughout the sdlc
privacy and security is super important
to our customers we've just heard that
loud and clear since the beginning and
that's why we're so excited to be
working with Google they view privacy
and Security in the same way we do and
and finally best in class so I talked
about having uh you know having AI
enhance multiple parts of the sdlc when
you talk about all these different use
cases different Foundation models will
be better for different use cases so we
want to be able to have the ability to
kind of pick and choose the right model
to explain a vulnerability the right
model to Summer Horizon issue the right
model to suggest a reviewer for an MR in
order to give our customers the best
experience that's great that's great and
and I I know we have partnered for quite
a long time and the customers I believe
are also very appreciative of of the new
features so my next question is there
are folks who are developers and and
will use the apis and also benefit from
it but what about the folks who have not
been introduced to coding what what do
you think like how can these generative
AI models especially the code related
models bring the folks those folks who
have been excluded from software
development into the mainstream yeah I
mean it's just a tremendous opportunity
to shorten the uh the learning curve and
and I think level the playing field
um by the way I'd love to steal your
prompt for the recipe generator that's
going to be super helpful in my
household I think uh you know a few
things I'd say there are number one
being able to provide kind of a pair
programming experience to somebody who
might be new to the field learning it on
their own in their free time or or even
on the job I think is super helpful
people learn well by doing as opposed to
kind of the abstract so being able to
generate kind of reference code is
helpful but also as I'm kind of making
my way through it and learning the
basics just seeing the suggestions that
AI you know can can make and having
somebody kind of look over the shoulder
virtually
um you know I think is super helpful to
kind of accelerate that learning in
context
um and I'd actually I think there's a
second opportunity that maybe is is less
obvious but maybe even more powerful
um you know I I spent 20 years in the
security industry and and you know came
to gitlab and
um you know because I'm super excited
but needed to get smart about devops and
you know I kind of had a casual
understanding of devops but needed to
get much much better at it
um and I I have to tell you that large
language models actually were super
helpful in that process
um you know I think for a few reasons
number one uh LMS are really good at
putting things into context that people
can understand so you can say hey look
can you explain kubernetes to somebody
who's an expert on security incident
response
um and you know it might be wow okay
what's the connection there LMS are
really good at it they can just kind of
give examples that you can understand
and I think that can shorten the
learning curve and be really helpful and
the other nice thing is there's no
judgment
um maybe the AI overlords are secretly
judging us but I didn't feel any
judgment
um that you know you can you can ask
questions that you might be afraid to
ask or you might be intimidated to ask a
senior developer
and so I think I can really shorten the
learning curve and make things more
accessible yeah that's great that's
great and and I think the the way the
apis and the models are evolving that
will definitely not only help beginners
and intermediates but even senior
developers can probably use it as a
reference so for sure uh and and finally
like how do you think Kodi API is being
integrated into gitlab all the products
how how are you integrating it uh any
thoughts you have on the upcoming plans
and how how do our customers leverage it
yeah we're thrilled with the partnership
uh you know it can kind of go back to my
principles earlier uh I think kind of
the shared kind of appreciation for the
importance of privacy is super important
from an actual implementation
perspective
um you know we've got uh 13 AI use cases
live on gitlab today across the sdlc
there's probably two that I think are
you know particularly relevant for
today's discussion you know the first is
a capability called code suggestions
which leverages uh you know the Kodi
family of models to actually provide a
similar experience so in context as as a
developers building it'll suggest you
know kind of it looks like you're you
know building a sort algorithm here or
it might you know fill out a case
statement
um with you know it looks like you want
more languages so super helpful
um you know capability uh you know that
that supports all the major languages
and the major Ides so so that's a great
capability the one that I'm even more
excited about I mentioned you know
having come from security for 20 years
is a capability called explain this
vulnerability which by the way all the
um we're committed to transparency all
the foundation models that we use are in
our documentation which is available to
the public so we're leveraging Cody
there as well uh and I I love this one
because I think the challenge with the
security industry that that frustrated
me for 20 years was we were trying to do
things top down I was trying to say you
know you know Implement these controls
and you'd have a disconnect sometimes
between the appsec folks and your and
your engineers and I think we're we're
explaining this vulnerability is so
powerful is it bridges that disconnect
and I've been in these conversations
they can be painful where
um you know it uh you train your
engineers as best you can but they'll
never be uh Security Experts and in the
same way your application Security
Experts need to kind of have familiarity
with writing applications some of them
are former Engineers but you know
they're not as deep in terms of of the
building side so you you have this kind
of tension there so I want to explain
this vulnerability can do is is actually
just in context in plain English it can
tell an engineer hey here's what this
vulnerability means here's why you
should care about it here's how it can
be exploited in the wild
um and it just facilitates those
conversations and makes them much easier
to have uh and and much smoother so um
so I think that's been a huge win
um you know for our customers and we're
super excited about continuing to build
out that roadmap that that's great
that's great thank you very much for the
partnership as well absolutely thank you
thank you everyone